funny how some Black Panther starts off
the scenes with the two white characters
there's one pretty white guy and another
pretty white hat
what's going on reject nation Greg Alva
here Shawn Humphrey here we're gonna
watch the official teaser trailer
presented by Marvel uh-oh for the
world's first black superhero really
getting his big screen solo adaptation
that is of course black panther teaser
trailer do this it's about damn times do
this Texans Shepherds cool outfits
explores a search for it
called it El Dorado
welcome to South America
I'm the only one you see it get rid of
timelines and base data life is changing
[Music]
[Music]
everybody looks so lol yeah it looks so
cool it's interesting to see how the
Marvel Cinematic Universe look seems to
be changing yeah there's any like
guardians to the thor ragnarok and then
this there is a similar type of visual
aesthetic to all three of the imageries
i've seen from watching guarding so
you've seen if the right and right row
they're now seeing this but that's
always the most interesting part to me
or that's one of the most interesting
parts to me because you know as we make
more of these movies they have to start
changing what they're like cuz we can't
just keep destroying New York City yeah
yeah you know and that's actually one of
the coolest things about this to me is
just like I feel like going to Africa or
Wakanda you know going to this African
nation really borrowing from that
imagery is yeah great new look you know
and I and I'm like that they're
immersing into the culture at least
borrowing from it for the mythology yeah
totally I think the Marvel Cinematic
Universe has been really cool about how
they've been sending up black panther
because you get any services crawl in
age of Ultron Ultron cuts off his hand
but that actually is supposed to happen
from black panther they change that
different yeah they change it around he
creates this like kind of sound like
weaponry he becomes this like superhuman
crawl he finds Wakanda and then all this
stuff starts happening he has this like
sound like weapon and then every Ross
Martin Freeman who's was a little bit
featured in Civil War he's a big part of
the Black Panthers story as well
oh so they've been giving like little
little spring clips of black panther
like setting him up and then not so like
obvious way pushing in your faces some
people might not even remember that andy
serkis was in age of ultron cuz he's
briefly in the movie and some people
will be like oh yeah mara freeman he is
in civil war right but they're they're
two very integral characters to the
whole black panther story that's
something that as much as i get tired of
crossovers that i think is a cooler way
to do that cool surprise like oh for me
yeah being less initiated i was like all
of andy serkis is
character and that wasn't distracting an
age of Ultron and it wasn't particularly
distracting here I thought that works
nice yes like oh cool I get it
every Ross is an important ally to Black
Panther oh and ulysses klaw is a is one
of black panthers primary villains okay
and a lot of you move a lot of people
were thinking that claw would be the
main villain but it sounds like he's
more setting up more of the world
because like with the animated series
that came out like seven years ago or
something that really focused on cloth
finding Wakanda him being the main enemy
throughout the series here it's like
okay they're already there where they're
picking up the timeline from is he's
already been to Wakanda and he's coming
back and he knows all about what Khanna
bean is technologically advanced part of
Africa because the whole story with
Wakanda is they have a meteorite that
crashes there which gave them vibranium
which is like what a suit is made out of
Captain America shield is made out of
iPad unobtainium yeah I'm liking where
they're going with this it's a cool
teaser trailer because yeah a lot of
because T'Challa Chadwick Boseman
black man through whatever part of his
story is he he leaves part he leaves
Wakanda and he actually studies in
America and he's the same thing what
Michael B Jordans character like longer
I think is manikyam longer kill monger
has the same thing too because his
backstory of kill monger from from what
I read as I did like an hour of research
like three hours ago today so I'm trying
to remember everything as his family was
exiled from Wakanda he went to America
he studied some [ __ ] they don't remember
but than II and then he eventually comes
back and he's supposed to be the primary
villain because he's one of Black
Panthers main villains too also Michael
B Jordan is playing one of the ultimate
Black Panther villains dam which is
really cool because he's worked with
Ryan Coogler several times as the hero
now he's working under he's working
under his direction but as a villain and
after playing Human Torch in a really
bad fantastic in a movie great fantastic
for me it's cool that they cut both
human torch's to play different
characters in the MCU guys we like you
deserve a second chance
and come home tomorrow yeah yeah yeah I
mean I really like the cats in this
thing I'm not fully up-to-date on all
the news and stuff but to see like Danai
gurira and yeah he didn't yawn go and
and you know Martin Freeman - I think
Chadwick Boseman is terrific and the
things that I've seen him in and and
Michael B Jordan I'm was really dazzled
by this trailer yeah at least you know
and I think you're right like that I
thought the music cues were cool like it
seems like it is allowed to be
distinctly its own thing especially for
some like black panther it's it's you
know it's the first predominantly
African American cast you know led by it
you know like an African American lead
let it blossom into what it is kind of
like Wonder Woman Olympic Gymnastics
omble is you know I know blade came out
Wesley Snipes yes and that was like
black superhero but in terms of like the
entire cast it taking place in Africa
because what Conda is of is a place in
Africa it's fictional of course yeah but
it's a place in Africa that is known to
be more technologically advanced than
most of the world and so I think it's
gonna be interesting to bring both sides
is watching the life like they're gonna
honor they're gonna honor the imagery of
what Africa looks like today and then
also bringing in the technically
advanced side of what Conda the
fictional side of Africa blending in
both sides of the world that's why I
think the costume designs look really
cool production design of the brief
imagery we got of Wakanda looks very
neat to me yeah yeah yeah and that's
that's probably the most exciting thing
to me is to go there and those are the
parts of world-building and to enjoy
yeah what is that world gonna look like
be like and you know when you get to
spend those sequences within just kind
of the culture what life is like there
it's a soy different world with inside
our world that's what makes it really
interesting yeah yeah yeah and they just
going to another planet that I didn't
yeah exactly and and you know I think
the more Marvel wants to broaden out
that way I think the better I don't know
if this film will have a villain problem
I know there has to be the main issue
with most comic book movies is the
villain issue because you know you got
crawling here and you got kill monger in
here and crawl you know they show in the
trailer that someone breaks him out yes
his team breaks him out of wherever he's
held captive it's so brief in the
trailer but either one of flashes of
different settings and stuff yeah but
crawl gets broken out and then you got
kill monitor in here and I'm assuming
they're gonna work together in some
fashion as well but it seems like the
big theme of it you know because we're
hearing that little speech going over it
to be king you know it's hard to be king
later you have to be a good person which
is an interesting thing to do because
chadwick boseman himself has said black
panther to him he was like an antihero
black panther goes down a lot of dark
emotional paths as well and it's also
picking up cuz the Black Panthers story
with two chala
originates from the fact that his dad
died and then he gave his prints in the
knee and the name actually becomes king
of Wakanda
you know they changed that too with
civil war with the bombing taking place
and then his dad doesn't change that
fact around as well the villain seemed
featured in here in in a nice way
like Andy Serkis looks like he's really
having fun chewing up some scenery
actually whereas Michael B Jordan will
probably play a little bit more on this
some more subtle side I'd imagine I hope
you know two different variations of the
villains I hope he gets to be a
character cuz at least from the few
flashes I've seen I know that it's easy
for at least what little I know about
that character I know it's easy for
those performances to fall into like
okay here's your one note your you look
angry a lot and you're righteously
pissed off at the main character and
you're gonna fight him until you die you
know and so I hope that that character
specifically gets to have more of an
emotional spectrum because like you know
Andy Serkis looks like so much fun and I
know Michael B Jordan has chops you know
as they're addressing their villain
problem and exploring things like I
think it could be cool to just have two
notable villains kind of team up in a
way or something like that it's possible
to be a good man in a king all at once
and then go out and take action all
mercè into that argument I think that
could be another thing that makes this
movie that much more interesting and
another thing you get like teases at you
know with the end of the rise of women
in action movies and superheroes
happening right now
you got this side of the spectrum where
it's the african-american cast within
that african-american cast there's the
door of Malati I think that's how you
pronounce it and where you got
characters like I suck at remembering
their names denying Google Guerrera
deploys Michonne Danai gurira
yeah and the beat Nyong'o yeah
you got like they're part of like the
all-female Special Forces that work
under Black Panther as well that's so
yeah you're gonna have lemon ISM coming
handsome feminism in the black side both
in one movie why the feminism just
includes the blacks oh yeah it's like
you know diapers casting and yeah well
female Special Forces look yeah yeah so
this I think this is gonna be one hell
of a special film for people I hope it's
done well cuz Ryan Coogler I don't know
him doing anything along the lines like
a black panther this being uh what's
what's the director's name again Ryan
Coogler Ryan Coogler this being his
first like massive scale thing I mean at
least what we see here in terms of the
action shots and stuff and the effect
shots look pretty good oh yeah totally
and I don't know how much of Marvel's
assembly comes from having certain
technical players on hand at all times
but I mean the action looks wicked and
the the way the shots are designed those
distinct well I'd imagine he'd be good
with that there's this really he'd shot
the movie Creed and there's this really
cool sequence in Crete where it's all
done in one take an entire boxing match
and this is shuttle and then knows how
to pan around it's perfectly staged and
even though that's on the crazy action
sequence it's still really badass
because he knew how to stage that to the
point where he could do it all in one
shot nice and so from just seeing how
knowing that one sequence made me go
this guy would probably be really good
at doing action sequences oh hell yeah
and it's show it shows in the trailer
like I definitely shows in the show that
one shot that everyone's probably gonna
be flipping out about with the car stick
Carl's Berkley yeah cuz black panther I
mean I'm one of they're gonna include
all his powers because he's got so many
powers I can't even tell you we're like
I'm sure if I try naming all them I
would greatly fail he has a ridiculous
amount of powers so I'm wondering if
they're gonna be able to include all of
that or will it be too much of an
overload for for this one movie and man
it would be cool it looks like every
outing he's developing a little bit more
like to show his powers you got it
showing you power every 10 minutes of
digital like that's just how many powers
he has he has so many bounders that
mental montage where they show him
mastery learning how
it'd be like 40 minutes and while it's a
fun trailer I heard this movie's gonna
have more of the serious Marvel tone
because you know Marvel is known for its
humor but I heard this one is gonna have
much more of a serious tone more along
the lines of how a lot of civil war was
or Winter Soldier was as opposed to you
know like ant-man or Doctor Strange kind
of vibe he's a pretty serious character
chadway it's a child a rather serious
human being well yeah and I don't know
what they're drawing from but you know
Africa is a place with a lot of a lot of
difficult history you know and
especially originating there and just
the notion that this is an advanced
civilization that they want kept off the
grid
you know I imagine there has to be some
pretty yeah serious subtext at work or
subtext to draw from I don't know how
much they're gonna take it's always a
hard line to skate I know we see some of
these in relays waiting series we see
some were like God's not serious enough
you know I think a serious tone for
something like this can work especially
when you look at that see like the scene
between Annie Circus and Martin Freeman
it's kind of indicative to me of
something that I think helps those
movies not feel quite so serious is when
characters at least crack smiles and
laughing I'm like people act like people
despite how heavy the circumstances are
and that's again the thing with like
Michael B Jordans character I kill
longer that I would worry about it's
like I don't want you just to be
stone-faced the whole time because
oftentimes that doesn't lead to a very
interesting villain or something like
that you know just because a serious
tone is there doesn't mean that you know
it's just devoid of all happiness yeah
like some movies we've seen like all
right yeah that was one hell of a
trailer I glad I waited around all day
for that one well you can subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell dad John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram social media manager of Blum
House comm check out our patreon for
exclusive verdicts and exclusive video
content over there you guys have a
wonderful beautiful weekend expect for
uploads like movie news of the week and
the mummy movie review